rt france régis le sommier il est en
direct avec mon
bon sens régis où la cedeao a également
décidé de couper les aides financières
et de geler les avoirs du mali à la
banque centrale des états de l'afrique
de l'ouest les sanctions plus
rigoureuses encore que celle adoptée
après le premier putsch d'août 2020
will est clairement il ya une volonté
justement de comment d'isoler le mali
est donc la junte militaire au pouvoir
pour la forcer essayez de la contraindre
justement à la tenue de ces élections
alors c'est un c'est nouveau les sextoys
voulez vous l'avez rappelé mais la
fermeture des frontières la fermeture
des espaces aériens là la fin des
transactions financières et surtout la
fin de l'aide financière au mali octroyé
par la cedeao qui permet au pays
justement de 2 comment de lutter aussi
contre
tous les mouvements de déstabilisation
qui qui agitent le mali en ce moment
donc il faut quand même rappeler aussi
que tout n'est pas non plus tout n'est
pas non plus fermé puisque les produits
de première nécessité pourront continuer
à circuler également les produits
pharmaceutiques
notamment tout ce qui concerne la crise
du coc vide est également tout ce qui
est comme en pétrole électricité donc on
ya pas une fermeture totale du du mali
avec ses pays voisins mais il s'agit
quand même de ces de sanctions très
dures qui interviennent à un moment où
le mali est en plein doute ça intervient
aussi dans le moment où la france a
décidé de ceux de quitter la région du
nord du mali pour se concentrer vers la
zone des trois frontières donc barkan
probablement vava comment va
s'interrompre aulas dans les mois qui
viennent il ya encore des troupes
françaises qui sont là et donc il ya eu
une forme de come ans d'atermoiements et
déstabilisation en ce moment au mali la
situation sécuritaire notamment dans le
nord et dans le centre du pays est
compliqué et il y a aussi surtout saluer
surtout ça en toile de fond aussi les
accords qui ont comme en ukraine qui
aurait été conclu mais nice il le
gouvernement malien déni comment leur
existence avec la société militaire
privée wagner là plusieurs sources la
semaine dernière ont d'ailleurs rapporté
que des véhicules circulant dans l'année
au sud de la ville de mopti donc aux
eaux comment au centre du pays d' entre
les deux villages de bandiagara bankass
est une zone contrôlée par la katiba
masinac est un des des groupes
djihadistes les plus actifs aux manies
et bien des incidents reconduit au
finalement et blessé un des mercenaires
de wagner effet les morts du côté des
soldats maliens et du côté des
djihadistes donc premier voilà ce qu ont
esquissé ce s'est passé la semaine
dernière un premier incident entre eux
wagner les forces maliennes et des
groupes jihadistes dans le centre du
mali donc c'est donc une situation
extrêmement tendue il faut s'il faut
bien regarder que mali aujourd'hui est
un pays qu'on peut qualifier inde et a
failli dans lequel les groupes
jihadistes
comment circulent comme ils veulent
parce que les autorités n'ont toujours
pas réussi à reprendre des pans entiers
du pays les services publics ne sont pas
assurés dans certains d'un certain
nombre de municipalités et la présence
même de l'armée parfois est très
aléatoire donc il ya très peu de
contrôles et le mali a besoin de pouvoir
contrôler son territoire donc ce n'est
pas évidemment avec le recul le retrait
de barkan à des français plus cet axe
asphyxie financière ou en tout cas cette
mise à l'index de la part des voisins
que le mali jusqu'à va pouvoir s'en
sortir dans ces conditions alors est-ce
que ça servira à infléchir la junte
militaire et a précipité le retour d'un
pouvoir civil vous avec ses des accords
qui ont été signés le président assimile
white a et son premier ministre un show
qu'elle malgaches se sont engagés à
tenir ces élections le prétexte de leur
côté que la situation sécuritaire ne
permet pas de tenir ses élections et qu'
il est illusoire de vouloir
lesquels des lieux à la date du 27
février il demande plus de temps la
communauté internationale la cedeao
considère qu' il s'agit pour la junte
militaire au pouvoir d'une manière
d'euros poussés l'échéance est de
conserver ce même pouvoir la junte
militaire à mayenne juge également
nécessaire des réformes préalables pour
que les élections ne souffre pas de
nouvelles contestations est ce que c'est
un argument recevable selon régis
écouter la question est de pouvoir que
toutes les parties au mali puisse se
présenter à ces élections et que lille y
ait un climat suffisamment serein je
pense que la donne sécuritaire et plus
un argument recevable que la question de
la représentativité ou en tout cas des
divers partis comme ces brandie par la
junte je pense que la question la
question sécuritaire c'est pouvoir tout
simplement amener des observateurs pour
prouver que les élections ont lieu et
puis surtout pouvoir amener les yeux
dans des zones qui aujourd'hui échappent
au contrôle de l'armée malienne op au
pouvoir central merci beaucoup pour
votre décryptage régis le sommier grand
reporter rt france